a biden campaign official is telling
jews to stop wearing yarmulkes
now the biden campaign official is
jewish himself he was the
i think he's jewish he was the lead
jewish outreach
guy for the biden harris campaign he
tweeted out it pains me to say this
but if you fear for your physical safety
take off your kippah
and hide your magen david i don't know
if i'm pronouncing that correctly
the star of david i suppose obviously if
you can
ask your rabbi first this is the wrong
answer
this is this is sad that he would say
this
because there is increased violence
against jews it's not like there are
pogroms or anything going on right now
but there is increased violence from
pro-palestinian people
that's true it's not from not from
conservative
christian republicans it's from
pro-palestinian people who i suspect
side with the left
and what this guy is saying is hey hide
your religion hide who you are hide your
identity
hide your religion that's the wrong idea
i hear this a lot
outside of the explicitly religious
realm in the political realm people will
sometimes say hey college kids
hide the fact that you're a conservative
just hide it just keep your head down
then someday in the future you can have
integrity wrong answer guys
courage is a virtue it's not just a
virtue it's the prerequisite
for all the other virtues if you don't
have courage you're not going to have
all any of the other virtues because
you're not going to be able to exercise
them not
surprised to see this coming from a
biden flag but really dispiriting to see
really awful awful thing to be telling
people hey stop before you go
just one second subscribe ring the bell
like it subscribe head on over by the
way to apple podcast google play spotify
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give you all
sermon about it
okay i'm not gonna go for hours and
hours it's very simple
do that and you will get the
notifications when we have more content
out there
see them